[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, і давайте
більше розважаємося з англійською Britain is great,
чи згодні ви опитування після
найважливіших слів англійської мови
Britain great okay,
тому Пол, як ви думаєте, що ми збираємося
обговорюємо сьогодні, можливо, великі люди для
Британії так, саме ми будемо говорити
про знаменитостей, але не тільки про
знаменитостей, але і про відомих людей
Великобританії добре, і хто є найкращими
британцями всіх часів. Я знаю, що в
2002 році був величезний телепроект так  тому
я прошу людей проголосувати за четверту найвідомішу
людину, так, і я знаю, що більше
мільйона людей проголосували правильно. Ви проголосували
я добре, хто був тут, за кого я голосував, як
просто смішне голосування смішний світ, як
гравець Челсі, чуття Челсі, чи він виграв
на жаль, ні, ні, можливо, наступного разу,
можливо, через 20 років вони пройдуть через 100
років, ми побачимо, добре, хлопці, і щоб
говорити про відомих людей, нам потрібно
помістити їх у різні категорії,
тому перше, що спадає нам на думку,
з  Звичайно, королі і королеви
Великобританії, тому що Британія все ще є
монархією, і, звичайно, ми знаємо щось
про династії і щось
про королів, добре, а потім приходять відомі
політики Великобританії Пол, який
спадає вам на думку, коли ви думаєте про
політика, ймовірно,  найвідоміший
допоміг нам виграти війну Вінстон Черчілль,
можливо, він або ваш нинішній прем'єр-міністр
Борисов
так, можливо, або Маргарет Тетчер перша
жінка-прем'єр-міністр
так точно, і я знаю, що Борис
Джонсон він пише велосипед на роботу, це
все ще правда, що він робив це, коли  він
був мером Лондона так, можливо,
тому, що, можливо, не зараз, тому що нещодавно у
нього був коронавірус, і тому він був у
лікарні довгий час, тому я думаю, що він
все ще на шляху одужання, він
на шляху до одужання, але, можливо, ми
його побачимо  на своєму велосипеді їздить вулицями
Лондона одного дня так і, можливо, п'ять таємних
поліцейських за ним добре, тоді приходять відомі
вчені Великобританії на урок
перед попереднім  ми говорили про
Майкла Фарадея та деяких інших
вчених, де вони в
списку тих 100 британців, яких я не можу пригадати,
чи були вони, але я думаю, що я пам’ятаю, як
Стівен Хокінг був на їхньому потоці
в Хокінсі, так, можливо, він був там, тоді
стає знаменитим  герої Великої Британії, і
тут у нас є сюрприз для вас, хлопці,
перший сюрприз, що героєм
буде жінка, тому насправді нам потрібно це змінити,
так що героїню,
можливо, ми побачимо, а інший сюрприз
полягає в тому, що це пов'язано з  Україна
насправді та відомі письменники
Великобританії Я думаю, що
зараз найвідомішим письменником є Джон Кі, який крутиться з вашими ро
анами про Гаррі Поттера, але я все одно не ду
аю, що вона така відома, як Вільям Ше
спір, ну ніхто не може перемогти Вільяма Ше
спіра, так, давайте перейдемо до
перша категорія, а ось і королева,
і ви повинні зіставити портрет з
людиною, добре, давайте подивимося, тому перший,
хлопці, подивіться на праву
частину сторінки і подумайте, хто ця людина,
і добре, що ви маєте  n дійсно
старомодний, але це не минуло
16 століття, я думаю, що це більше,
ніж сер, тому я думаю, що це королева Вікторія
так, і це вона, так що Пол, що ви
знаєте про цю особистість, а для мене
її найважливіший успіх був  той
факт, що вона
була лідером
імперії, яка все ще вважається однією з найбільших імперій, виправте мене,
якщо я помиляюся, але я вірю, що
Вікторіанська імперія була найбільшою
контрольованою населенням, тому жінка на
чолі однієї з найбільших імперій коли-небудь
це досить успішно так, це
цікаво, так,
наступна королева добре, тому я думаю,
що це не більше, ніж Єлизавета, я
думаю, що це Єлизавета перша, а
Пол, чому вони мають це перше, а
потім ми можемо побачити Єлизавету другу, чи
вони вірять в ті самі сім'ї  чи
це сестри, ні, очевидно, що у нас
є безліч королів або королев з
однаковими іменами, щоб ми могли розрізнити, але
це також показує династію, яка походить від
мм-хм, і що спільного між
королевою V  Ікторія і королева Єлизавета в
перший день з однієї династії насправді
королева Вікторія була останнім Тюдором
Моннеттом, і ось єдиний король у
цьому списку король Генріх п'ятий
Ланкастерський, і він дуже видатний
король і зарекомендував себе як
солдат  Британські королі б'ються,
чи повинні вони добре служити армії,
усі вони вступають до армії, чи до флоту, чи до військово
-повітряних сил. Я не пам'ятаю так далеко
про їхній військовий
досвід, їхній військовий досвід, але я пам'ятаю, що у нас була
війна у Великобританії 80-х років
у 80-х була війна у Аргентині
Фолклендських островів, і я пам’ятаю, що
двоє принців або, безперечно, один
із принців був пілотом гелікоптера на
тій війні, і, мабуть, вони кажуть, що він бачив
бій добре, тож давайте продовжимо, і ось
приходить  остання королева точно не є
королевою Єлизаветою, друга, і вона
все ще жива, вона народилася в 1926 році,
яке довге життя, і вона є найдовше
правлячим монархом в історії в усьому
світі найдовше правлячою мімуною
Ви можете повірити, що добре, хлопці, тож тепер
давайте перейдемо до наступної категорії та відомих
політиків Великобританії, і, як Пол
сказав, що його улюблена держава
– сер Вінстон Черчілль, чому,
очевидно, він був лідером
країни під час війни, а я  ця
країна виграла війну за допомогою своїх
союзників, тому його можна назвати одним
із найуспішніших прем'єр-міністрів
коли-небудь, і він дійсно дуже важлива
людина не тільки для британського народу,
але й для всього світу,
хлопці, наступним завданням буде
завдання з читання, яке ви будете читати після
Пола про сера Вінстона Черчілля, і
перед завданням читання давайте подивимося на
питання, на які ви повинні будете відповісти
після читання, добре, давайте переглянемо
запитання, тож скільки разів Вінстон
Черчілль намагався скласти вступний іспит
до Королівського військового коледжу, що
сталося з Черчіллем у 1900 році, добре, Пол, чи
можете ви прочитати третє запитання,
що робив Черчілль, коли був першим
лордом Адміралтейства, добре і  номер
чотири, коли Вінстон Черчілль
став прем'єр-міністром, добре тоді, коли
відбулася Друга світова війна, і про що
застерігав Черчілль після
Другої світової війни, і коли Черчілль
отримав Нобелівську премію, так, хлопці, тепер,
будь ласка, слідкуйте за Павлом, читаючи Вінстона
Черчілля, так  Вінстон Черчілль був
відомим британським політиком і письменником.
Він був британським прем'єр-міністром під час
Другої світової війни і привів Британію до
перемоги над нацистською Німеччиною Вінстон
Черчілль народився в аристократичній
родині 30 листопада 1874 року в школі,
він був незалежним і бунтівним
учнем.  погано впорався, і в квітні
1888 року його відправили до школи-інтернату Харроу
поблизу Лондона, його батько
вирішив надати йому армійську кар’єру,
Вінстону знадобилося три спроби, щоб скласти
вступний іспит до Королівського військового
коледжу, але коли він туди потрапив  він був
хорошим учнем у 1895 році, батько Черчілля
помер у тому ж році
Черчілль приєднався до британської армії та
служив в Індії та Африці в 18  99
Черчілль залишив армію і працював
військовим кореспондентом,
він записав свій досвід в історії
польових сил Макклеллана 1898 року
та річкової війни 1899 року в 1900 році. Пошуковик
став членом парламенту від
Консервативної партії, у 1904 році він
змінив Ліберальну партію, коли він  був першим
лордом Адміралтейства, він допомагав
модернізувати британський флот,
він також захоплювався польотами
та бойовими літаками в останній рік Першої світової
війни він став міністром
боєприпасів у 1922 році Черчілль залишив
Ліберальну партію і знову приєднався до
Консервативної партії, на якій він служив
шанс на шашку в 1929 році Консервативна
партія програла вибори і Церква, яку він
вийшов з уряду, він провів
наступні кілька років, зосередившись на
написанні й працював над своєю книгою
Історія англомовних народів у 1930-х
Черчілль побачив небезпеку  гітлерівської
Німеччини 3 вересня 1939 року
Черчілль був призначений першим
лордом Адміралтейства після замаху 1940 року
Черчілль став  прем'єр-міністром
і міністром оборони
він поставив розумних і талановитих людей
на ключові посади, він тісно співпрацював з
США.  Президент Франклін Рузвельт і
лідер Радянського Союзу Йосип Сталін
союзники виграли війну в 1945 році після війни
Черчілль провів шість років як
лідер опозиції, застерігав від
панування СРСР у Східній Європі, у 1951 році
повернувся до уряду і був
членом парламенту -  у 1964 році в 1953
році він отримав Нобелівську премію з літератури
Вінстон Черчілль помер у своєму
будинку в Лондоні 24 січня 1965 року у віці 90 років,
тому, хлопці, давайте трохи обговоримо текст,
перш ніж ми перейдемо до питань, добре,
тому Пол, ви прочитали, що він народився  для
аристократичного сімейного права чи означає це,
що його сім'я була багата, а не просто багата,
а вони були багатими і досить благородними, а
потім мудрість Черчілль приєднався до британської
армії і служив у кількох кампаніях
відразу після того, як полюбив армію, він
добре працював робітником?  і
, ймовірно, саме з цього почалася його кар'єра
письменника, так, так, мабуть,
бути журналістом у
зоні бойових дій, мабуть, дуже важко, і
цікавий факт:  що він модернізував британський флот
, це дуже цікаво, так як одна людина
може багато чого змінити, тож він
знову полюбив Ліберальну партію і повернувся
до консерваторів, повернувся туди, де його
серце належить так, як консервативний
ліберальний консерватор, а потім він
став правим канцлером  і вони програли
вибори так, і він витратив кілька
років на написання і роботу над своєю книгою,
тому книга назва книги - це
історія англомовних народів,
цікаво, що ми зазвичай не використовуємо
це слово у множині, а в основному це
множина  люди так, можливо, це тому, що
англомовні люди в різних
країнах люди тут мають на увазі нації,
коли ми говоримо про різні нації, ми
можемо використовувати для мене слово народи Вінстон
Черчілль є видатною людиною,
тому що він був одним із перших,
хто побачив небезпеку  Гітлерівська Німеччина
і він були першими, хто почав боротьбу
проти нацистів, цікавий факт
про Вінстона Черчілля полягає в тому, що хоча
вони були  У зв'язку з Радянським Союзом
він міг бачити зло, що йде від цієї
держави, і він не був у світі проти
радянського панування в Східній Європі,
на жаль, його ніхто не слухав, і
ми мали величезне панування Радян в Східній
Європі, добре, якщо
цікаво, що він воював
я вважаю, що він був у парламенті до самого кінця,
тому він повернувся до парламенту
після того, як пішов у відставку з посади прем’єр-
міністра і прожив дуже довге
життя 90 років
, це дуже довге життя, тому, хлопці, ви
готові відповісти на запитання, які я
Відповім на перший, тож скільки
разів Вінстон Черчілль тричі намагався скласти
вступні іспити добре
батько змусив його це зробити о, можна сказати, що
він мав наполегливість і рішучість,
я не впевнений, що це було його бажання, але
його батько  був справді сповнений рішучості віддати
свою бунтівну дитину до військової
школи, так що трапилося з
Черчіллем у 1900 році, Пол, ви пам’ятаєте,
можливо, він був військовим кореспондентом, добре, він
став членом натовпу  парламент
від Консервативної партії, і ви
пам'ятаєте, що він перейшов їх на ліберальну
так, я знову надто консервативний, тому
я третє питання, що
робив Черчілль, коли був першим
лордом Адміралтейства так, я знаю цього,
Боже, так  тому що це військово-морський флот, і я
пам'ятаю, що Генрі восьмий був добре відомий
тим, що заснував флот, а
Вінстон Черчілль був добре відомий
модернізацією флоту, так, він
модернізував британський флот, а потім номер чотири,
коли Вінстон Черчілль став прем'єр-
міністром, так було і в  між словами
чи це було якраз перед
світовою другою світовою війною ні це було
між війнами так так це було після
початку другої світової війни
так і він не він був не тільки
прем'єр-міністром, але й
міністром  міністерство оборони оборона так дві
посади одна людина добре номер п'ять
коли почалася Друга світова війна і це
я знаю, що одна 1945 так у 1945 і у
вересні так і що Черчілль
попереджав ще раз  Після Другої світової
війни піднесення комунізму так
радянське панування в Східній Європі і
дуже цікавий факт, тому він отримав свою
Нобелівську премію за Летицію
так за літературу, а в 1953 році я думав,
що він отримав би її за мир,
як Нобеля  Премія за
твір, але насправді за літературу, це
означає, що його роботи справді
видатні, лише додаткова трішки
навчання для наших студентів у 1953 році ДНК,
холод для ДНК був виявлений у
Кембриджському університеті, дякую вам того
ж року ДНК холод і Черчілль дав свою
Нобелівську премію за  Література добре
цікава добре давайте рухатися далі, так що
відомі вчені
Великобританії не хлопці ви знаєте деякі з них
добре давайте подивимося тепер завдання полягає в тому, щоб
зіставити біографії з людьми, то давайте
подивимося імена Джеймса, що Стівен Хокінг
Чарльз Роберт Девон  і сер Ісаак
Ньютон, отже троє людей належать до фізики,
а один належить до біології, добре, давайте
почнемо з Джеймса, що Пол, чи можете ви знайти
його біографію так, Джеймс, добре, я d  я не
пам'ятаю, щоб він був відомим винахідником, але
я пам'ятаю, що він щось значно покращив,
тому я б перейшов на паровий
двигун, так, так, щоб Джеймс
покращив паровий двигун,
і наступні також, а Вільям Хук,
на жаль, вчені померли не так
давно  у 2018 році, він
фізик-теоретик і добре відомий своїми чорними дірами
і квантовою гравітацією, він був інвалідом через
хворобу моторної сечі, і він не міг
рухатися, але це не могло обмежити його ідеї
дивовижна людина так, добре,
тоді приходить Чарльз Роберт Дарвін, це
мій  улюблений із цих чотирьох, тому що
я не дуже добре знав фізику чи хімію
в школі, мушу зізнатися, але мені справді
подобається біологія, і тому еволюція Чарльза Роберта
Дарвіна так
, це теорія еволюції
та теорія еволюції та походження видів, добре,
і остання  сер Ісаак Ньютон і
Пол, чи вірите ви в цю історію
з яблуком і ним, що сидить під яблунею,
так, це дуже гарна історія, я думаю,
я вірю в неї  це з
британськими вченими,
добре, хлопці, і як ми обіцяли,
ми поговоримо про героїв і ми будемо
говорити про жінку-героя, тому її
звуть Флоренс Найтінгейл, і вона
дуже відома медсестра Пол, ви
пам’ятаєте  часів, коли вона жила
, це були 1800-ті, так, 1800-ті, і вона
була медсестрою під час військової
кампанії Кримських воєн, так що ви
будете слухати історію, і вам потрібно
розставити речення в порядку, тому знайдіть
хвилинку і перегляньте всі
речення  добре, хлопці, тепер ви
послухайте Пола, він розповість вам історію, і
ваше завдання — упорядкувати речення
, щоб історія Флоренс
Найтінгейл Флоренс Найтінгейл була
медсестрою, яка врятувала багато життів у 19
столітті, її назвали на честь міста
Флоренція в Італії, куди її батьки поїхали
після одруження в 1818 році, її
сім'я була багатою, вони мали два будинки в
Британії, а також слуги Флоренс була
незвичайною молодою жінкою для свого часу,
тому що вона не хотіла ходити на вечірки
і вийти заміж, вона хотіла бути медсестрою
і допомагати людям, її сім'я не хотіла,
щоб вона стала медсестрою, тому що
лікарні тоді були брудними,
жахливими місцями, вони переживали за
неї в 1851 році. Флоренс поїхала до Німеччини і
дізналася все про медсестринство, це було важко
робота, але вона любила це в 1854 році багато
британських солдатів пішли воювати в
Кримську війну. Армійські госпіталі були
заповнені пораненими, але не було
дитячих,
і багато чоловіків померли Флоренс, а
команда медсестер йшла на допомогу Флоренс, працювала
20 годин на день, щоб  зробити армійський
госпіталь чистішим і безпечнішим місцем вона
приносила чоловікам свіжу їжу вона прибирала
лікарняні ліжка і використовувала чисті
пов’язки на поранених солдатів, щоб
менше чоловіків вмирало вночі Флоренс
ходила по госпіталю вона розмовляла
з пораненими солдатами і допомагала їм  чоловіки,
щоб писати листи своїм родинам, вона
носила лампу, а солдати називали
її дамою з лампою, коли Флоренс
повернулася до Англії, люди називали її
героїнею, тому що  про її дивовижну роботу
на кримській війні
королева Вікторія написала їй листа з
подякою, вона продовжувала наполегливо працювати у
Великобританії над покращенням госпіталів, і їй
вручили медаль, яка називається орденом «За заслуги»,
вона була першою жінкою, яка отримала цю
нагороду, добре  хлопці, подивіться на
речення ще раз і послухайте, щоб потягнути
ще раз, тому історія про Флоренс Найтінгейл Флоренс
Найтінгейл була
медсестрою, яка врятувала багато життів у 19
столітті, її назвали на честь міста
Флоренція в Італії, куди пішли її батьки
вони одружилися в 1818 році, її
сім'я була багатою, вони мали два будинки в
Британії, а також слуги Флоренс була
незвичайною молодою жінкою для свого часу,
тому що вона не хотіла ходити на вечірки
і виходити заміж, вона хотіла бути медсестрою
і допомагати людям  її сім'я не хотіла,
щоб вона стала медсестрою, тому що
лікарні тоді були брудними,
жахливими місцями, вони переживали за
неї в 1851 році Флоренс поїхала до Німеччини і
дізналася все про медсестринство, це була важка
робота  але їй це подобалося в 1854 році багато
британських солдатів пішли воювати в
Криму, армійські госпіталі були
заповнені пораненими, але медсестер не було,
і багато чоловіків померли Флоренс,
і команда медсестер пішла на допомогу Флоренс,
працювала 20 годин на день, щоб зробити  армійський
госпіталь
Діна та безпечніше місце вона приносила
чоловікам свіжу їжу вона прибирала лікарняні
ліжка та використовувала чисті бинти на
поранених солдатів, щоб менше чоловіків
вмирало вночі Флоренс ходила
по госпіталю вона розмовляла з пораненими
солдатами та допомагала їм чоловікам  писати
листи своїм сім'ям, вона носила
лампу, і солдати називали її
жінкою з лампою, коли Флоренс
повернулася до Англії, люди називали її
героїнею через її дивовижну роботу
в Кримській війні
королева Вікторія вельми вітала її, щоб
подякувати, вона продовжувала  наполегливо працюйте у
Великобританії, щоб покращити лікарні, і їй
дали медаль, яка називається орденом за заслуги,
вона була першою жінкою, яка отримала цю
нагороду, добре, хлопці, ні  готовий з
вашими відповідями Я сподіваюся, що ви розставили їх
у правильному порядку я маю на увазі
речення, і перше з них: Флора
19 років жила в 19 столітті, вона
хотіла бути медсестрою і допомагати людям
давайте подивимося інші відповіді давайте
подивимося все  історію, а ви перевірте, чи правильно
ви це зробили чи неправильно, добре, тому
друге речення має бути таким у
1851 році Флоренс поїхала до Німеччини і
дізналася про медсестер, а номер три
у Кримській війні не було медсестер
в армійських госпіталях і багато чоловіків загинуло,
тому  що відбувається, зроблено Флоренс зробила
армійський госпіталь прозорішим і безпечнішим місцем,
тому менше чоловіків загинуло, вона почала те, що
ми знаємо як гігієна, правильна дуже проста
річ мити руки дуже важливо
сьогодні, тому принципи були ті ж
двісті років тому, а тепер мити
руки хлопців потім приходить номер п'ять
вночі Флоренс розмовляла з пораненими
солдатами і допомагала чоловікові писати
листи так що це означає, що вона працювала день
і ніч дуже важко працювала окей
жертва жертва
Потім приходить дівчина номер шість, вона носила галуни,
і солдати називали її жінкою
з лампою, можливо, вони навіть не
знали її імені,
але вони знали, що вона була там, щоб допомогти
їм, шість, а потім приходить сім, коли
Флоренс повернулася до Англії.
у неї хороший слух і вона
продовжувала наполегливо працювати в Британії над
покращенням лікарень і їй дали
медаль, це дуже цікава історія
про одну жінку з Британських островів, але
є один хлопець, який жив на
території сучасної України так, я думаю, що
я  знай цього
Ольга, я не знаю його імені, ти можеш
сказати мені його ім'я, але я пам'ятаю, що багато років
тому я їздив на екскурсію до черепного
міста недалеко від Києва, що називається Венеція,
і там є чоловік, який забальзамував тебе,
як опудало, і ти можеш  бачу, як він
несе каву, і я пам'ятаю, що він мав
щось відношення до того самого
часу, що й Флоренс Найтінгейл, так, вони
жили в один час і насправді
воювали в одній війні, але були
на різних сторонах і  ця людина
Микола Іванович Пирогов і він
відомий військовий хірург і це
дуже цікавий факт, що Флоренс
з британської сторони помітила, що
якщо помити руки, то можна
краще лікувати рани те ж саме помітив
цей чоловік, але перебуваючи з іншого  сторона
цієї військової кампанії, і він також
відомий винаходом гіпсу та
речі, яку вони використовували в операціях, щоб
нас спати, чи стоматологів, коли ви
так довго їх брали, були початком того, що я
ніколи не міг це сказати чи пам’ятати, і
Анастасія  Анастасія правильно так дуже
цікавий зв'язок міс Флоренс
Найтінгейл і Миколи Івановича
Пирогова як людей, які воювали
один з одним, але вони зробили величезний крок
у гігієні добре, хлопці
Британців знають у всьому світі, але ви
знаєте цих хлопців, хто вони  і
насправді ваше домашнє завдання виконується,
можливо, з ними, можливо, ви б хотіли
зробити проект про якусь відому британську
людину, але на вашому місці я б зробив
щось смішне я б вибрав, можливо, нам
потрібен Пух або
Телепузики, я все ще пам'ятаю їх
імена, коли дивився цей серіал
з дітьми, тому тепер виберіть будь-яку відому британську
особистість, створіть проект, як вам
подобається, і розкажіть нам про свого кумира або розкажіть
нам  про ваш зразок для наслідування, тому я знаю, що
Пол має цікавий факт про сера
Вінстона Черчілля, коли ви робите свої
презентації, намагаючись додати цікаві
факти або щось смішне, щоб зробити вашу
презентацію яскравішою.
у більшості
великих столичних міст
є багато пам'ятників, ми маємо
Трафальгарську площу, лорд Нельсон Чарльз,
перші багато-багато пам'ятників, але,
на жаль, у Великобританії, а особливо в
Лондоні, у нас є багато голубів,
мільйони голубів, і ми знаємо, що гени P люблять
ходити до  туалет скрізь,
особливо на пам'ятниках, тому влада Лондона
повинна завжди очищати
пам'ятники від усіх голубих туалетів, яких вони
ніколи не повинні  чистий
Вінстон Черчілль Старий пам'ятник Вінстону Черчіллю на
Парламентській площі біля будинків
парламенту є єдиним пам'ятником, на якому
ніколи не було голубиного туалету,
і це тому, що через нього проходить електричний
струм, тому
голуби не підходять до нього і не підходять  приземлиться на
нього, і тому Вінстон Черчілль, тому що він
дуже важливий, має найчистіший пам'ятник
у всьому Лондоні, тому використовуйте електричний струм
і нехай ваші пам'ятники
безкоштовні, хлопці, сподіваюся, що вам сподобався
цей урок, і ми сподіваємося побачити вас наступного
разу та розважитися на відміну від  Флоренс
Найтінгейл сказала мити волосся
під
[музику].